the Russia hand is strobe Talbots new
memoir of his State Department days he
spoke recently at the Council on Foreign
Relations in New York City with Newsweek
International editor for Reid Zakaria
recalling his time is President
Clinton's top advisor on Russia mr
Talbot offers an eyewitness account of
the evolving relationship between
Clinton and Boris Yeltsin and describes
how he and his State Department
colleagues tackled arms control the
expansion of NATO the ceasefire in
Chechnya and American missile defense
this program runs just under an hour
nice to see you all right I'd like to
welcome you all on behalf of the council
this is a very special meeting for two
reasons one we have stroked all but with
us and to this is on the record I I
think it inevitably is on the record
because their cameras here for c-span
but I thought I'd begin by introducing
our guest not that he needs much of an
introduction I've also I've always
thought that I had an interesting career
as a young journalist but then I
discovered when I was very young that
stroke tall but when he was I think 22
years old 23 years old began translating
nikita khrushchev's memoirs this
happened when he was at Oxford as a
Rhodes Scholar what I did not know until
I read his his book is that the man who
helped him get through those that
translation mostly by cooking omelets
for him was Bill Clinton who was his
housemaid at Oxford at the time from
their stroke goes on to an extraordinary
career at Time magazine ending up as
their foreign policy columnist he then
joins the administration as a special
adviser on Russia or actually on all
former Soviet states and then becomes
deputy secretary of state so I guess the
first question I would ask strobe is you
went in one of these very rare shifts
from being an observer of foreign policy
at the highest levels to actually being
a practitioner of foreign policy at the
highest levels what's the thing that
surprised you most what's the big change
well first freed thanks for doing this
and thanks to all of you for joining in
this conversation
this will sound a little bit like a
wisecrack perhaps I don't mean it that
way in some ways the the biggest
surprise about going from outside the
door through whose keyhole I'd been
looking all of those years to the other
side was that there weren't too many
surprises I think that many of us
looking at government from the outside
assume that there are secrets into which
one is initiated both secrets of
information and secrets of procedure
that make the world easier to for our
public officials to deal with I don't
know if this is good news or bad news
but it ain't so the other I've been I
had of course studied the workings of
government and particularly foreign
policy and particularly the making of
policy towards the Soviet Union and
Russia for a long time and yet even with
that background I had expected there to
be more by way of if not recipe books
than at least a kind of an
infrastructure of knowledge and
procedure that in fact was the case the
other thing that didn't really surprise
me but that certainly impressed itself
upon me early on is the the consequences
of decisions when you know I was in your
line of work for 21 years it's the only
profession I ever chose I loved it very
very much and one of the great things
about journalism is that you can take a
new crack at a tough issue every week
maybe some of your readers Henry maybe
even some of your editors will notice if
you change your opinion from time to
time but when you're in government and
at work helping others make high policy
it's you have to stick with
the line and see it through and course
correction is a lot harder than it is
observing from the outside and
commenting from the outside I I want to
begin the substantive leave asking you
in a sense why you wrote this book
you're there are two they've always been
two kinds of people who observe the
Soviet Union people who were interested
in Russia and people who were interested
in the Soviet Union I remember talking
to a friend of mine who was a professor
of Soviet studies as the wall was coming
down and he was deeply dismayed because
he said what I was interested in was
this weird social experiment called
communism being imposed upon this big
society and the consequences it had
around the world now all I'm left with
is Russia and I was never that
interested in Russia in the first place
now you've always had an extraordinary
interest in russia russian literature
russian art russian music is is that
part of the reason why you chose to
write to focus this book on russia
because you were by the end the Deputy
Secretary of State you were dealing with
all kinds of issues why is this book
focused in on that one relationship well
I suspect in some ways what you imply is
true and that is that I was indulging a
personal long-standing interest in that
country on America's relations with that
country I had done a number of previous
books and this is a kind of another in a
series i was on much better terms with
my principal source this time and i had
ever been in the past but beyond that
which is personal and really parochial i
felt i don't think there's too much
dispute about it that the us-russian
relationship is of immense if not unique
importance that this presidencies
attempt to deal with that relationship
would loom large in how that presidency
is ultimately judged by by history
moreover the extent to which the state
to state relationship was crystallized
in the personal relationship between the
two presidents struck me as more than
just an interesting fact but of real
operational significance in terms of the
results of the policy President Clinton
and President Yeltsin met 18 times
that's as many times as all nine of
President Clinton's predecessors going
back to Harry Truman and the Potsdam
meeting with Stalin had bet with their
Kremlin counterparts put together and
beyond the the quantitative uniqueness
of the Clinton Yeltsin relationship it
was also both intense I think in some
areas and will no doubt want to talk
about that quite productive and it was
also fraught with great difficulties
some of which were rooted in what was
going on in Russia others of which were
rooted in difficulties in the United
States and with the Clinton presidency
and still others inherent to the
relationship itself and I wanted before
too much time had passed to put down the
story as I had both seen it and lived it
now I don't make any claims to this
being the definitive account of what
happened obviously there's always a
Russian law in effect other people will
have different perspectives and I hope
and do course others who participated in
the policy will write their own versions
of things but because so much of us
Russian relations was transacted at the
presidential level and because i was at
President Clinton's usually right hand
the note-taker I did have a unique
perspective on it and I wanted not only
to get down the factual record but also
to recall as honestly and fully as I
could how things look to us at the time
what we what we felt we were dealing
with what we saw the trade-offs to be
and why we made the decisions that we
did but the book is wonderfully written
and one of the things you get a sense of
in the book is the relationship between
Bill Clinton and
boris yeltsin but I want to ask you
about that it does seem as though the
relationship got extremely personal in
the sense that there was an enormous
personal reliance on Yeltsin and a
belief that yeltsin personally was going
to transform russia or that supporting
yeltsin personally was very important
that you recount a time where as soon as
Clinton is elected he says I want to go
and meet with Yeltsin because he wants
to meet with me he's obviously in
trouble and a meeting with the American
president would show him up some people
have criticized that kind of emphasis I
remember Henry Kissinger once saying it
foreign policy is not psychotherapy with
reference particularly to one of these
bill and Boris meetings how would you
respond to Stewart to a charge like that
well I've read Henry Kissinger's memoirs
and I can assure you that he certainly
pot practice some psychotherapy on his
counterparts over the years obviously
foreign policy is not just personal
relations and certainly not just
psychotherapy but the relationship
between the American president and the
Russian President does have
extraordinary importance and i would say
particularly during this particular
period where russia was undergoing a
transition from a very different kind of
state in the old soviet union even
though there was always a top guy he
presided over a system that made the
decisions in the case of Russia of
post-soviet Russia that system had
pretty well collapsed and much of the
decision-making power did reside with
one man Boris Yeltsin regardless of
whether we thought he was a good guy or
a bad guy or wanted to call him a friend
or a partner he was going to make the
decisions and therefore we or anybody
would absolutely have to deal with them
and as it turned out on those issues
which were mostly in the foreign policy
area that is that have to do with
Russian Foreign Policy and behavior
broad President Clinton by engaging with
Yeltsin and developing this personal
bond was able to get President Yeltsin
to come around two positions that we
felt were certainly in the American
interest and we would have argued did
argue in the Russian interest as well
again talk about some of those but they
include everything from stopping the
sale of Russian rocket engine parts to
the Indians to getting the Russian
troops out of the Baltics on time to
bringing the Russians into a position of
some acquiescence with NATO enlargement
to having the Russians participate under
NATO command and Vulcan peacekeeping and
so forth and so on those issues simply
couldn't be done at a lower level I was
I worked very closely obviously with my
two immediate bosses Warren Christopher
and Madeleine Albright I worked with
them as they tried to get these issues
resolved with their various Russian
counterparts in the foreign ministry and
with Yeltsin himself and what we heard
over and over again from Yeltsin was
this is too important to leave to you
people this is something bill and I will
have to decide which is one reason that
President Clinton had to keep going back
there and having those meetings what was
he like Yeltsin will will history look
at him as a great reformer as a Democrat
the man who killed communism or will it
look at him as the man who created an
extraordinary oligarchy in Russia who in
a weight stigmatized the very idea of a
market economy because he allowed a
privatization that was really a kind of
privatization that went directly from
cat from communism to robber baron
capitalism with nothing nothing
intervening or since what's what's your
sense of what people will think of them
well all of the above and then some will
be part of the of the the nuanced and
complete judgment of course but you're
asking me for kind of a bottom line and
i think that the bottom line will be
positive and i think you touched on it
in the menu that you gave me to pick
from I think the
important lasting contribution of Boris
Yeltsin will turn out to be that he did
drive a stake through the heart of the
soviet communist system now looking back
on the early 90s and the mid 90s it may
be hard for people to remember how very
dangerous and uncertain those times were
particularly in 93 when Yeltsin was
locked in a showdown with the Soviet era
Parliament but again in 1996 when he was
written off by just about everybody
except for Bill Clinton in the race for
the presidency with you not easy gone
off there were other outcomes very
imaginable for Russia and I think
Yeltsin strengths included a absolute
stubborn determination that he wasn't
going to let that happen another
strength that he had was that even
though he was deeply conflicted and
contradictory about as a Democrat he
used to use the verb in Russian which
derives from the word czar such thoughts
you would say I when he would say I'm
commanding something or I'm making a
decision he would he would use a word
which meant as though I were as are but
on a number of key occasions he did let
the people decide he let elections go
forward even though he came close to
pulling the plug on the elections in
1996 he did let those elections occur
and by the way President Clinton used
some influence with him at the time the
weaknesses God knows we can talk about
they were there they were very
conspicuous the extent of which his most
famous bad habit obtrude even on the
private relationship with President
Clinton
and and really I think contributed to
some pretty scary moments that is his
boozing will be more apparent to those
of you who read this book but it
certainly won't come as a revelation
that he had that problem as well as
others I don't want you to go out
running to buy this book if you think
they're going to buy do vast details
about by the Elton's boozing but let's
take the you know what some would argue
was a one of his most serious mistakes
indeed a mistake that the Czar's had
made before him the way in which he
handled Chechnya it's not simply that it
violates human rights in all kinds of
ways which it does but it seems to have
not solved the problem it seems to have
placed Russia in a kind of Perpetual
military campaign just at a time when it
needs to you know to solve its own
Algeria problem if you will if you use
the French analogy and focus in on on
reform did you try to make this this
case to him and why do you think he was
so unresponsive well let me start with
the the Maricopa here and I do even
dwell on this in that chapter of the
book I think we the American side and I
personally as somebody who bore some
responsibility as an advisor to the
president were much too late in
understanding the magnitude of the
threat that the war in Chechnya posed
not just to the the miserable and
long-suffering people of the North
Caucasus and not just to the Caucasus
region as a whole but to Russia itself I
think it's not the most original
metaphor in the world but it's
appropriate I think Chechnya really is a
cancer on the body politic of Russia's
infant democracy and could kill it
particularly now that there has
in a recurrence now with regard and and
we just didn't see that we weren't
paying enough attention to that remote
corner we were preoccupied with lots of
other issues I would argue reasonably
important ones but we did not understand
the importance of this one that was
coming up at us out of nowhere we we
came to see it and we put the issue very
much on the on the agenda now with
regard to Yeltsin without making any
excuses for him and the extent to which
he let himself I think more than
anything being manipulated at a time
when his health in general was not good
into the first war in Chechnya he did
get Russia out of that war he empowered
general leben to negotiate a ceasefire
which involved significant concessions
to the Chechens and the war did end in
1996 now at some point the name Vladimir
Putin will probably come up in our
conversation and we can talk about the
second chechen war but my point here is
that chechnya was in a way
characteristic of a more general pattern
that we saw in with Yeltsin he would
sort of stumble and lurch and bluster
and kind of awkwardly throw himself
about in getting to the right position
he's never should have gotten into the
war in Chechnya but he did get himself
out and his successor got Russia back
into the war and shows no sign of
getting out that's an important
difference between the two there are a
lot of other differences we can talk
about well let's talk about him since
you brought him up the again one could
if one would it be wish to be a critic
one could say the Clinton that the
Clinton administration misread Putin
that Vladimir Putin comes to power and
seems to be treated by the Clinton
administration as a kind of low-level
KGB flunky who's you know who's come to
power and isn't going to amount to much
and he seems to have at the very least
asserted a kind of control
indiscipline over a decision making that
is quite extraordinary has been able to
sign a whole series of deals rather
effectively with with the new
administration do you think you you
missed something in him when you were in
the first meetings you bet and so did
everybody I do not know anybody who saw
and Vladimir Putin when he was deputy
mayor of st. Petersburg or when he was
the head of the Security Council or when
he was the prime minister the potential
even for making it to the presidency
much less being as successful in many
respects a president as he has been I
dealt with him in three of those four
capacities that he held before he became
president of russia and i was astonished
when President Yeltsin designated him to
be his heir apparent I think by the way
that yeltsin who no doubt was operating
on the advice of family and friends saw
and putin some things that we did not
fully appreciate including the extent to
which Putin was kind of the onion that
is he was different from Yeltsin in so
many conspicuous respects that he would
appeal to the Russian electorate that he
would have a calming influence while
Yeltsin had kept Russia roiled up all of
those years in other words I think that
in some ways a last piece of evidence of
Boris Yeltsin's surviving political
acuity was his designation and indeed
manipulation of Putin into the into the
presidency do you look at what Putin is
doing now the accumulation of power the
he's weakened the regional governors
he's weakened the Duma the parliament
he's weakened pretty much every
competing source of authority while at
the same time appearing to produce some
kind of movement on economic reform tax
reform things like that is this a kind
of finish up model that would will work
or do you think at the end of the day it
is not going to be good for Russian
democracy
to have a kind of super presidency well
the honest and short answer is I don't
know I am confident that when we end up
when we have enough experience in
perspective to make a judgment we will
not be talking about a penis a model I
suspect we may be talking about a Putin
model which will be quite different and
we may see that model adopted elsewhere
if it continues to be reasonably
successful in Russia in some ways of
course every leader wants to minimize
the extent to which competing sources of
power and decision-making can get in the
way of his program there's nothing new
and net it is also the case that Russia
had become borderline chaotic in its
political structure a lot of the
regional leaders the governor's and so
forth that Putin has reigned in or not
believe me philosopher kings or
Jeffersonian Democrats you know their
whole swatches of Russia and the old
Soviet Union that are kind of you know
Jurassic theme parks for the bad old
days of this of the Soviet Union so we
shouldn't shed too many tears about
about all aspects of that what worries
me about Putin and where I think that
the the instincts that derive from his
alma mater that is the KGB are most
dangerously apparent is with regard to
the independent media and with regard to
Chechnya which we've already touched on
I guess if I could just make freed one
more point that is about our influence
over I think we have a lot and I think
President Bush has at least as much
influence over President Putin as
President Clinton had over President
Yeltsin and perhaps more what we saw in
September 11th and the Russian response
to sep tember 11th which was by the way
Vladimir Putin's response was a
intuition I think probably that occurred
to Putin in a matter of hours that
September 11th represented a strategic
opportunity for Russia to accelerate its
alignment with the west and that was
rooted
in Putin's conviction that if Russia is
going to succeed if he is russia's
president is going to succeed Russia has
got to go west and that means of course
largely in terms of the economy but more
generally and we can talk more about
that but the point is he knows the
importance that the United States has as
the chairman of many of the boards as it
were and an influential presence even in
those organizations that the United
States isn't a member of like the
European Union and the Council of Europe
and so forth and so on and that means
that we have the ability with him to say
there are still norms and rules that you
and Russia have to abide by if you're
going to get the full benefits of
integration and those rules and norms
notably include matters internal to your
country we were past the point we got
past the point I think in the 90s at
least where the the defense of
impenetrable sovereignty prevented these
issues from figuring on the
international agenda that's what the
wars and the Vulcans were largely about
and I think Putin does understand that
but I think we're under playing that
influence now Chechnya has pretty well
fallen off the list of discussion points
between the United States and Russia
right now and I haven't heard very much
about the Free Press either do you think
you mentioned several points in the book
that Clinton was obsessed with the idea
or at least concerned about the idea of
coming up with a kind of successor
phrase of not doctrine to the idea of
containment you describe this
fascinating conversation at one point
between yourself Warren Christopher and
George Kennan and cannon tells you for
God's sakes don't come up with a
successor phrase of the problem with
containment to the extent that there was
one was that it was a bumper sticker
rather than a paragraph post-september
11th do you think we have come up with a
phrase and are you comfortable with
the age of terrorism the war on
terrorism ah no I don't have a better
one I'll let me just tell you a little
follow-up on the anecdote that you were
hope that you just recounted i sat down
with President Clinton and I told him
about the conversation with George
Kennan and I was trying to basically get
President Clinton to relax a little bit
on this phrase mongering issue and just
not worry quite so much about what we
were going to call the era in which we
live we could really pay more attention
to the substance and I said you know
George Kennan made a strong argument
that we should think in terms of
paragraphs rather than bumper stickers
and President Clinton sort of rolled his
eyes and he says well that's why George
cannons a terrific professor and you
were at the riffic journalist but you're
not politicians and politicians not only
for their own purposes but for purposes
of communicating to their larger
constituencies do need to have labels
for the era now the the folks associated
with George W Bush used to gigas on this
issue too and after September 11th
secretary Powell proudly proclaimed or
not proudly proclaimed emphatically
proclaimed that we were now in the we
had seen the end of the Cold War of the
post-cold war era this by the way is
something that a colleague of mine at
Yale John Lewis Gattis had said a couple
of weeks before so what phrase has the
Bush administration come up with for the
new era the post post Cold War era that
will fit on a bumper sticker but I don't
think it's going to last and I certainly
hope we're not in the age of terror let
me ask you one question before we open
it up to to the audience Russia has gone
through as you know these waves of an
attraction toward the west and then a
repulsion not a repulsion or they said
distancing itself from it the cry great
debates between the Western Isis and the
slava files of the 18th and 19th century
do you think Putin is Putin's move to
the west part of a broad secular change
or do you believe that there is still
danger of the
historical cycle repeating itself I I
asked this because as you know many
people within Russia are quite critical
of Putin for the moves that he has made
and given that you know capitalism
doesn't have a terribly good rap in
Russia right now democracy has an okay
rat Putin's westward moves if something
goes goes bad is there a danger that
that we move back to a kind of isolate
isolated russia yeah and of course the
choice you're giving me is not
completely either or i mean both both
propositions i think can be true my
sense and it's obviously highly
intuitive is and no doubt reflects some
wishful thinking is that Russia if all
else permits will leave its own version
of exceptionalism behind and join the
rest of the world and the great debate
between the slava files and the Western
I zors will be resolved in favor of the
latter I think by the time that that
happens maybe Western Iser won't be the
right term anymore it will have more to
do with internet global community and
global global culture but it one of the
reasons that I insofar as there's
anything empirical underlying my
conviction and hope it's my sense that
this the split is largely generational
the younger people that I know in in
Russia seem to have joined the world and
are comfortable with the idea of Russia
joining the world in a way that older
folks are not that's not too surprising
of course but i think it is it is
positive but there any of a number of
scenarios where things could go very bad
and Russia could slip backwards or in
very ugly way sideways no doubt about it
well now the more interesting part which
is your questions could you wait for
microphone so that we get to get this
recorded and we'll move on button and
you should identify yourselves please
but my design the Harriman professor at
Columbia University um from
Gorbachev to Yeltsin to Putin it would
seem to me that all the three presidents
put in so far have emphasized foreign
policy very activist foreign policy and
have had successes in foreign policy but
both Gorbachev and Yeltsin had a sort of
a sinking star trajectory with respect
to their own populations in terms of
their own popular in terms of their own
popularity do you think as a historian
as a foreign policy analyst and a
foreign policy maker that Putin will end
up with a similar fate or do you see
something different in him as a
tactician as a slow mover where he might
have greater successes on the domestic
front also which is what is necessary
well I think your last question which of
course you've written a lot about
yourself is critical you know it's the
it's the economy stupid principle if the
Russian economy continues to make modest
but nonetheless unmistakable progress
that will obviously greatly help the
standing whoever the President of Russia
is but I think yes Putin stands a pretty
good chance of leaving office more
popular than either as predecessors now
that's not saying a whole lot given that
Gorbachev was the most unpopular man and
the Soviet Union at the end of the
Soviet Union and Boris Yeltsin came
pretty close to the same distinction in
fact Gorbachev was more popular than
Yeltsin in Russia at the end of the
Yeltsin presidency but there are as the
Soviets used to say objective reasons
for those two earlier cases in the case
of Gorbachev the unpopularity was I
think largely derivative of the fact
that the state over which he presided
was collapsing around his and everybody
else's ears now some people applauded
that and felt good riddance to Gorbachev
other people hated it and blame
Gorbachev for the fact that it was
breaking up as for Boris Yeltsin to some
extent what I'm about to say is not his
fault although to some extent it
but it is again objectively true that
during virtually all of his presidency
Russia was a great roiling mess it was
constant chaos it was one showdown in
crisis after another a lot of people in
the room who know Russia very well I'm
sure they heard the same thing from
their Russian friends the Russian
Russians would tell me all the time you
know we are suffering from crisis
fatigue and President Clinton worried
about that I remember after one trip i
think it was in 97 he said you know I'm
really worried about this country and he
was an optimist about Russia he said
this is a country that seems to be
undergoing a non-stop what did he say
emotional breakdown and it was really
true and what when I would ask Russians
well what do you most want from your
next president this is towards the tail
end of the of the Yeltsin period the
word that they would use in Russian
means basically normalcy we want just
you know for all this shouting and
screaming to stop so that we can in some
sense get on with our lives and I think
to some extent Vladimir Putin has either
been able to bring that about or able to
get himself identified with that having
come about I think a little bit of both
and if there can be a significant
continue to be not too much in the way
of constant crises in Russia that will
keep his popularity reasonably high
serve the back just but it was one other
thing one reason that that Putin is able
to make himself the normalcy President
of Russia is because Boris Yeltsin got a
lot of stuff out of the way earlier on
my name is John hartzell from Dresner
Bank the president in the vice president
in the last few days have started
talking about a first-strike doctrine
which would have been horrendous back in
the old days but I guess my question is
is
the doctrine whose time has come is
specifically in the context in this case
of terrorists and and even terrorist
nations or terrorists labeled nations is
this the doctrine whose time has come is
it a dangerous departure and how does it
impact on coalition building first of
all I guess with the Russians I think
that they're certainly may be cases
where a preemptive defense or what is
oxymoronic Lee called preempted
deterrence may be may be required I
don't think we should rule it out and by
the way we never have ruled it out it's
always been a kind of footnote to or in
the small print of American strategic
and defense doctrine so I don't think in
that sense it's a radical new departure
insofar as it's getting the kind of
emphasis as it is by the administration
I think it's going to be quite
problematic particularly in terms of our
ability to close some riffs that have
developed with our key allies our
ability to assemble coalition's for what
may well be an inevitable and very
necessary operation in Iraq I think it's
all so troublesome with respect to the
Russians although we have I don't think
too many Russians worry a lot about this
doctrine being used against them that's
actually I think one of the significant
areas of great improvement in the
relationship when I was working with the
Russians on the issue of national
missile defense which was only a year
and a half two years ago the Russians
were very concerned then that the
combination of national missile defense
and American strategic capability both
nuclear and conventional did mean that
we were holding open the possibility of
striking them first that seems to have
faded considerably but in a way it's
kind of indicative or paradox of our
times that we have a lot more disputes
on matters of what you might call
strategic culture with the West
Europeans and we have of the Russians
but I do think it there's going to be
trouble and I suspect we're going to see
a pragmatic president
this concept as he continues to talk
about it Maurice can use good Maurice
temples Minh one of the challenges that
President Putin faced when he came to
power was to stop and reverse the
centrifugal forces to basically sort of
tearing what was left of Russia part he
seems to exceed has succeeded to some
extent in doing that but considering the
limitations of history institutions and
power levers of power that he had do you
think he could have done this in a
different way that might address some of
your concerns about the free press and
the democracy of that yes I think he
could have done it in a better way and I
hope he does do it in a better way over
time Russia is not going to make it as a
normal modern unified country integrated
with the rest of the world unless it
continues to develop as a genuine
democracy a pluralist democracy and I
think because of the very size and scope
of the country as well as its ethnic
makeup it's going to be have to be a
highly federalized or federated
democracy and insofar as president
Putin's current measures cut against
that I think he's buying problems down
the road we've already talked about
Chechnya Chechnya is a major threat to
the unity of Russia Islamic extremism is
far greater in the North Caucasus today
than it was ten years ago because
largely of the scorched earth policies
that the that the Russian authorities
have carried out there and because of
the extent to which good old-fashioned
racism which has never been very far
below the surface in Russia has come
back to the surface and that has
implications for all of the culturally
Islamic parts of Russia the other issue
of course is the economy
when I'm first went to Vladivostok in
the late 80s I think it was you know the
people I was surrounded with there were
for the most part ethnic Russians with a
few Ukrainians a throne end so they had
no cultural sense of isolation or
distance from Moscow but boy did they
ever one out of the Soviet Union and
that was basically for economic reasons
and so Putin has as he pursues what I
think is basically a reformist economic
policy has got to give a lot of
attention to the economic development of
the far problem the Far regions of the
country you mentioned America being the
chairman of the chairman of the board's
well we also have a chairman of the
board who's been patiently waiting to
ask a question thank you latrobe how are
you I'd like to pressure that on the
oligarchs and privatization when David
and Rockefeller and I took a group their
number of years ago we were astonished
which is to say utterly dismayed by the
macro corruption that was implicit in
the notion that you give half a dozen
favored few political supporters
billions of dollars worth of
interest-free loans that they then
proceeded to buy vouchers at a penny or
two on the dollar using a lot of
government money and given the
unbelievably on a competitive nature of
those industries these oligarchs as far
as I can say contributed almost nothing
to the revitalization of these
industries no fresh capital infusion no
technology don't know how or or anything
now when we press to bias for why on
earth did they do that we got two
explanations one was a very tepid and
thoroughly uncredible reason that they
didn't have a good Treasury payment
system and they needed to go through the
private sector but the one more
passionate one was it was transcendent
that they moved to
market mechanisms and since there was a
pretty good chance the Communists were
going to win they wanted to make it a
reversible because lord knows the
Communists would never have permitted
industry to fall into private hands
could you give us your analysis of why
they did that well I agree with you Pete
the first argument is bogus I didn't
even heard it before but it's bit I can
easily imagine to by saying that the
second argument of course had a
political force or appeal to it in the
time frame when we first heard it which
was 95 and 96 that was the period when
they they undertook the so-called loans
for shares a program which was basically
this kind of very exclusive orgy of
inside trading made available to the
oligarchs so that they could buy up many
of the assets of the old Soviet state
for ridiculously low prices in exchange
for their political financial and media
support for President Yeltsin in the
campaign against you gone up in 96 and
remember of course that you gone off was
consumed to be on a roll there there are
people whose judgment I respect who make
the the argument that yeltsin didn't
really need the oligarchs to win and
that by the way the oligarchs so needed
yelton to win that they would have
supported anyway even if it hadn't been
for the loans for shares scheme I can
believe that it's a counterfactual but
it's a plot it's a plausible one there's
no question that the oligarchs are a
multiple disgrace and drain on Russia
for the reasons that you say and also of
course they have inspired a lot of
disillusionment among regular Russians
with the economy with the reform with
democracy with support from the west and
so forth so there's a price that we're
gonna day and therefore we are going to
have to pay for a long time too
I guess the last point I would end on is
predictive but I it does have some
plausibility to it and that is the
theology arcs are a passing phenomenon I
can see how a number of them are already
trying to respectable eyes themselves in
several ways I'm sure one of them
thinking about starting up a council on
foreign relations in downtown Moscow and
they're certainly approaching American
universities including a couple I know
very well and that's more in the
symbolic realm they're also looking for
ways to keep their vast amounts of money
in Russia and invest in Russia and
that's really the key point Russia has
got to become a genuine law of rule of
law society and economy if it's going to
succeed economically that's the bottom
line I think on the economic issue I
wonder if Stan Fischer has something to
say or ask stan was of course the number
two men at the IMF for a very long
distinguished career always my number
one guy thanks thanks trope incidentally
on the previous question the oligarchs a
lot of the oligarchs are actually
transforming at the moment in order to
protect their property they're becoming
respectable but what's interesting about
it is that i was told that in 92 and 93
and 94 that it was going to happen and
it has happened as predicted I'm sure
this is in the book but the question
want to ask you is there been lots of
criticisms of the eight process I wonder
if you could address two of them the one
is we the West should have been far more
generous at the beginning and generous
throughout and there never was any major
infusion of foreign funds into Russia
despite what we were being told at the
time and the second is that we were far
far too interventionist shouldn't have
used the IMF and the World Bank if we
were going to aid the Russians we should
have given the money and told him to get
on with it and do very little about
trying to redirect their economy
I seem to reflect on both these things
in the book but what is it yeah I do
Stan I do feel that we by which I mean
not just the Clinton administration but
the first Bush administration of whose
policy by the way I'm generally very
admiring and Michael Beschloss and I
wrote an earlier book giving the first
president Bush a lot of credit for we're
kind of being the ground controller for
Gorbachev as he brought the Soviet Union
in for a soft landing but I do think
that there's a lot more that we could
have done early on particularly in the
area of technical assistance and
exchanges people-to-people programs
helping them an institution building and
that kind of thing as you know very well
Stan because you were wise counselor to
me on this a couple of times there was
an effort that was well-intentioned had
some promise but never really came too
much in the 93 period to build into the
g7 sponsored programs that the
international financial institutions
were carrying out in the Soviet Union a
strong element of social safety net so
that as this process of privatization
went about the workers who were thrown
out of work would have some compensation
the workers who went to who kept their
jobs but the jobs were now privatized
would still have the benefits of health
care and child care and that kind of
thing that was part of the Tokyo package
as you remember from that year and it
just we didn't do enough we didn't we
and our g7 partners didn't sustain that
effort I think had we done so it it
might have it might have helped what I
don't lie is the notion that we should
have bypassed the EFI's and simply
shoveled money into Russia I think that
the problem that Pete identified a
moment ago would have been even more
extreme we would have been shoveling a
lot of that money into pockets which
would have had big holes in them and the
money would have ended up in Switzerland
and the river
london banks and that kind of thing
Larry Summers and I spent an awful lot
of those eight years trying to get right
the issue of conditionality and I
recount in the book couple of
fascinating debates between Larian &
Cherney mirrodin and prima cough about
the kind of conflicting laws or rules of
economics on the one hand with Larry
arguing the case and and politics of a
primitive but real and democratic kind
that were happening in Russia and we
never got that we never were able to
reconcile that point the stringency is
required fiscal and other stringent seas
required sound economics and the the
requirements of Russian politicians who
had to face voters
I'm rolling Paul with a barian Howard in
the reception our you and I talked very
briefly about another war the war in
kosovo and of course as we all know you
had a central role in bringing about the
settlement of that war in dealings with
the Russians you you praised a chair an
American in that regard but surely there
must have been some basic element in the
us-russian relationship that got them to
turn their back on their ally in a way
they did if that's a fair way to say it
to achieve the peace we needed you know
it was it was the single hairiest
episode of my my experience and I think
in many ways one of the most revealing
it's also a dramatic an example as
you're likely to get of the importance
of the Clinton Yeltsin connection
because in order to end the war on
NATO's terms and in order to get Russia
to throw its weight behind the effort
that Marty Otto sorry of finland was
involved in with me working with him to
basically pressure Milosevic into
accepting those terms Bill Clinton had
to call in all of his Jets with Yeltsin
and there's another institution that
played a role here that I give quite a
bit of attention to and that is the g8
much has been made and much fun has been
made of the re-designation of the g7
into the g8 the g8 of course existed for
one reason and that was to give a forum
that was very high-profile 24 where
Yeltsin could sit down as an equal with
the other g7 there was a g8 meeting
coming up in cologne and we basically
use the argument with Yeltsin repeatedly
you're going to either have to boycott
that meeting because the war is still
going on are you going to have to go to
that meeting and walk out and turn a
personal triumph into a public
embarrassment or you're going to have to
help us in this war and that means
getting Milosevic to pull out a Kosovo
and accept
turns it worked but boy I'll tell you
getting there was not half the fun the
if there is one one episode from the
book that I would recommend it's the
scene in the Russian Ministry of Defense
the night after the bombing had stopped
but while NATO was poised to go into
Kosovo and I had gone to Moscow to
negotiate with the Russians the terms of
Russia's participation and the
implementation force that was about to
go in to Kosovo under NATO command and
before my very eyes I watched the high
command of the Russian military which is
to say the minister of defense the chief
of the general staff the top GRU a
military intelligence guy lie to me
repeatedly about the status of a Russian
unit that was making its way from Bosnia
towards Kosovo and we had every reason
to believe was about to go into Kosovo
without coordinating with with with NATO
and therefore setting up a confrontation
between Russia and NATO we were about to
snatch big-time defeat from the jaws of
victory now you know fortunately my
colleagues who would accompanied me to
Moscow were sitting outside the room
Rose conductin we're watching CNN so
they know exactly where the Russian
forces were and were able to send me in
notes from time to time but there was
there were a number of pieces of
evidence that night that the Russian
High Command was on its own and I don't
know if that's because Boris Yeltsin was
indisposed or what but i think it was
not only a disturbing episode for those
of us who witnessed it but i think it
obviously had an effect on the russian
civilian leadership and they put in some
additional measures after it was over it
ended well however and it ended well
because Boris Yeltsin wanted to go to
the g8 meeting in Cologne as a hero
which he did and he wanted to go with
all these issues that had been so
contentious including within his own
government resolved and we were
basically able to say here are the terms
that will
to resolve keep calm
strobe as a Russian ax stand a fellow
Russian 'used I'd like to ask you a
question about poverty sure there's
considerable dispute about how many
Russians have fallen into poverty since
1991 reasonably it's somewhere between
35 and seventy percent depending on how
you set the poverty level the government
today says is 55 dollars a month that
doesn't seem reasonable to me but
whatever the case an enormous number of
Russians have fallen into poverty and
Russian sociologists tell us that many
of them were middle class people like
ourselves which may be without precedent
in a previously at least semi modern
country during the 90s reading he saw
two soviet ologist statements of the
clinton administration some of us had
the impression that you were the only
person who worried about this question
of poverty in Russia there was his
famous statement you made that more
therapy and less shock was needed I
understand that you later regretted that
remark but I interpreted to mean that
you were thinking about this issue of
poverty and then you gave a speech
subsequently I think at Oxford on the
occasion of Isaiah Berlin or some event
that I read and there to you alluded to
it so the question is this um as you
watched poverty grow in Russia in the
90s what did you think I mean you see me
love russia or care about rush in a deep
way obviously what did you think about
this did you feel any i don't know what
did you think about it and looking back
since so many are still in poverty what
do you think about it in two respects in
a humane way humanitarian what me and
strategically in that this is the first
time so far as i know that a fully
nuclearized country has been
impoverished and nobody knows exactly
what that means but it can't mean
stability well Steve just on the yep
freed says this this was this is the
last question so this is the last answer
the I regretted having used the the
irresistible sound bite what Russia
needs is less shocked and more therapy
precisely because it was a cute
soundbite and of course drove the
Russian reformers who were trying to
apply modern discipline economics to
their country absolutely nuts didn't
earn me for that day any accolades in
the Department of Treasury either i
might add but it was the was a correct
analysis and i never have recanted the
point that i was that i was trying to
trying to make by the way i was not by
any stretch of the imagination the only
person in the US government who thought
about this concurred about this and i'll
tell you who else thought about it cared
about a lot and that was the russia hand
bill clinton and he didn't see anywhere
near as much of it as i did but i can
remember going there when we went to st.
Petersburg and down the mosque Moscow he
as he was driving around looking out the
limousine window he said you know a lot
of those people either one way or
another kind of giving us the finger he
said they don't like us very much
they're mad at us for some reason and he
said I think I know what it is and that
is they've whole lot of hardship and
heartache has come with this transition
and you know we got to do so I'm not
going to do the accent okay we gotta do
something about that and that's still I
think it's the it's the economy stupid
now the only point that I would put sort
of counter to the trend of our little
dialogue here where we're kind of in
sync is the good old days the good old
days weren't the good old days there was
an awful lot of poverty in the Soviet
Union that got disguised through phony
statistics just as there was an awful
lot of corruption and criminality which
like everything else was privatized in
the early 1990s but the main thing is
that the citizens of the old Soviet
Union were not real citizens and any
sense of the word that we would
recognize and they were profoundly
impoverished in the sense that they were
living under a dictatorship and Russians
now
the vote they can they can they can vote
in referendums they can vote for their
officials and over time let's hope that
they vote for officials who will make
that country as the Russians like to say
a normal modern country I think they've
got a very good shot at it but we
obviously have to help them in every way
we can thank you very much
she'll defend quite the evening and
you'll I get your autograph strobe
Talbot was deputy secretary of state
during the Clinton administration and
will assume the presidency of the
Brookings Institution later this year
the Russia hand is published by Random
House for more information or to read an
excerpt visit their web address at
random com